Cabin in the Woods cabin fever and who
can forget Cabin Boy it's the story of a
boy and his love affair with the sea M
Night shyamalan's knock of the cabin
joins a long line of illustrious
cabin-themed movies but is this one
worth your time in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the story some
of its hidden Clues and whether or not
Dave Batista can act
famously huge turds and you'll want to
stick around near the end of the video
to find out just who exactly these four
intruders are so strap on in and hit
that like And subscribe button because I
may not cover every show you watch but
when I do it's fantastic the first shot
of the film is of a grasshopper in fact
grasshoppers are a recurring Motif
throughout the story and symbolize
taking a leap of faith just like our
characters will have to do if they're
going to prevent the apocalypse more on
that in a bit meet win a precocious
seven-year-old on vacation with her two
dads at a secluded Cabin in the Woods
she's out collecting these Grasshoppers
and putting them in a glass jar so she
can learn about them the Grasshoppers
and the glass jar becomes a metaphor for
the characters themselves they are
trapped and can't escape they must take
a leap of faith and hopefully we'll
learn something about them the more we
observe wins grasshopper collecting is
put on hold when a mysterious man by the
name of Leonard played by Dave Batista
shows up from seemingly nowhere although
he's a Hulk of a man covered in scary
tattoos his demeanor couldn't be further
than his outward appearance he's calm
soft-spoken and empathetic soon
befriending Young when and helping her
catch more grasshoppers when even notes
that he's good at catching them and
other metaphor since Leonard will be in
a way capturing her family he asks her
about this scar on her mouth something
she was born with as a baby in China
where she was adopted by her two gay
dads Leonard says he has something
broken to his heart and it's broken for
what he's about to do throughout this
day when and her parents will have to
make a terrible decision a decision that
could affect every last human on earth
suddenly three others appear from the
force Dawning makeshift weapons it's
clear these people aren't here to make
friends in fact Leonard doesn't call
these newcomers his friends rather
people he works with when runs to alert
her parents who quickly lock themselves
in the cabin to protect themselves from
these weapon-wielding nut jobs they'll
soon realize there's no cell service and
the power to the cabin has been cut
leaving them completely at the mercy of
these strangers Leonard wants to be let
in so they can talk on a matter that
puts the very fate of humanity at stake
but when's parents Eric and Andrew are
understandably not too keen on letting
these guys in so when they tell them to
go away The Intruders smash their way in
and take them by force tying the Two
Dads up so they can't escape the
newcomers introduce themselves and they
all seem to come from different walks of
life there's Leonard the second grade
teacher from Chicago Redmond a gas
company worker Adrian a line cook at a
Mexican restaurant in Sabrina a nurse
the four of them have been drawn
together through a series of Visions
Vision so strong it compelled them to
seek each other out and these Visions
include a series of plagues the first
being cities that drown the second a
plague and third Falling Skies
culminating in a darkness that will
descend over Humanity Eric Andrew and
win must make a choice sacrifice and
kill one of the three of them to save
all of humanity and this can't be done
through suicide or by accident failure
to do so will result in humanity being
destroyed and the three of them left to
roam the empty Earth as Leonard States
they're not the first family that has
been given this choice of course Eric
and Andrew think this is all [__]
they've been taken over by lunatics and
that becomes a driving force for much of
the movie R Leonard and his team for
real or is this some kind of crazed cult
to make matters more interesting each of
intruders have watches perfectly timed
for when one of these plagues hit they
know because they've seen it in their
Visions now Leonard will offer them four
opportunities throughout the next 24
hours or so to make this sacrifice
should they say no a plague will be
released which brings us to their first
chance to stop the apocalypse
understandably Eric and Andrew call
[__] which leads to one of the most
chilling scenes in the movie Redmond
gets on his knees and Dawns a white
cloth over his head and says the
following line a part of humanity has
been judged and as the other Intruders
brutally murder him I found it
interesting that as The Intruders
undergo this ritual it's almost as
though they're out of their bodies
performing like machines as if someone
else is controlling them after it's over
they snap back to reality and remove the
body Outdoors but what comes next is
truly chilling they turn on the
television to see that an 8.6 magnitude
earthquake has hit only 70 miles off the
coast of Oregon unleashing a devastating
tsunami that will go on to kill hundreds
of thousands but that's not enough to
convince Eric and Andrew especially
Andrew claims they must have known about
this earthquake before they got here as
it would have taken several hours before
the tsunami hit the coast to make
matters even muddier we find out two
important facts one The Intruders
initially met on a message board which
could mean they're all partaking in some
sort of shared delusion too Andrew
thinks Redmond was the guy who bashed
his head in with a bottle in a
homophobic attack several years earlier
an attack which had a traumatic impact
on his life and prompted him to learn
self-defense and buy a gun this gun will
come in handy later on Eric and Andrew
believe each of The Intruders has motive
for participating in this apocalyptic
fantasy Leonard is the mentally
maladjusted leader Sabrina is a
religious nut job Adrian is simply
delusional and Redmond is a bigot it's
not too long before the family are asked
for the second time if they will
sacrifice Adrian pleads with them to do
it as she has a son who will die in the
coming apocalypse should they choose no
unfortunately for Adrian they don't
agree and she's next on The Chopping
Block she dons the white cloth and says
the same line a part of humanity has
been judged and she is promptly killed
it doesn't take long for a television
news report to come on that talks about
a devastating flu killing hundreds of
thousands of particularly young children
around the world with a steady increase
in cases but again Andrew dismisses it
this flu has been around for months just
because there's been an uptick doesn't
mean there's any correlation with what
just happened meanwhile Wen has managed
to grab a knife from breakfast and hand
it to her father to free him from his
bonds he rushes to the car where he
stashed his gun later killing Sabrina
this unleashes the third plague over 700
aircraft across the world crashed from
the sky still Andrew doesn't believe
this could have been the work of
terrorist hackers so they locked Leonard
the final Intruder in the washroom with
the hopes of escaping via his car but
when they hear him trying to escape
through the window and get to that car
first they go in and are attacked
Leonard is shot in the arm and his
Escape is unsuccessful he asks one final
time if they are willing to sacrifice
and they say no he says they'll only
have a few minutes to change their mind
one final time when he suddenly slits
his throat and says all of humanity has
been judged this Begins the final plague
the one that will lead to the
destruction of all of humanity the skies
darken lightning bolts cast fire into
the forest and planes fall from the sky
if Eric and Andrew aren't Believers in
now they certainly should be Eric even
refers to the four Intruders as the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse each of them
setting off plagues with when taking
refuge in a nearby Treehouse Eric and
Andrew debate which of the two of them
should die Eric is ready and willing to
be that sacrifice but Andrew holds back
Andrew doesn't believe Humanity should
survive he's seen the hate Humanity
creates he's experienced it firsthand as
a human rights attorney and chooses only
to see the bad in others Eric on the
other hand chooses to see the good he
sees it every time they look into their
daughter's eyes he wants their daughter
to have a future not alone with them on
a desolated earth there's also a scene
where Eric says he felt a presence a
figure of sorts in the light hinting
that there's a God and he's ready to
meet whatever awaits him Beyond with
that Andrew takes that leap of faith
just like a grasshopper shoots and kills
Andrew and the apocalypse is reverted
with when safely by his side Andrew
finds the intruder's car inside a few
items that prove they weren't lying
about who they were such as a photo of
Adrian and her son the radio players
Casey and the Sunshine bands Boogie
Shoes which was the same song on Eric's
playlist that played on their way up to
the cottage the two ride off into the
distance as the film ends now is knock
at the cabin any good I unfortunately
was disappointed there was no real twist
as is common in Shyamalan movies and I
felt the film's broader themes such as
sacrifice didn't stick The Landing but
what did you think will it rank up there
with the sixth sense and unbreakable or
do we have another happening on our
hands let me know in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
I have famously huge turns
foreign